-After the first
presidential debate,
many Americans were left
with mixed feelings.
Here to talk about it is one
of our writers, Jeff Wright,
in a segment called
"The Wright Thing."
♪♪♪♪
-What it do, Seth?
-Hey, Jeff,
so, what did you think
about the first
presidential debate?
-I think the Black community
is owed an apology.
-From President Trump?
-Nah.
-From Joe Biden?
-Nope.
-Then from who?
-From America, Seth.
-Why do you feel that Americ
owes the Black community
an apology?
-Several reasons.
Mainly slavery.
But America needs to apologize
for its lies.
-Lies?
-Yes, Seth, lies.
For several years, everyone made
it seem like only Black people
were ratchet and loud,
but it turns out those title
should be reserved
for the presidential debate.
-Oh, because of
all the interrupting.
-Yeah, I didn't know if I wa
watching the presidential debate
or "The Real Housewives
of Atlanta."
-Oh, I love that show.
-Me too!
Especially when -- Remembe
when Porsha got into it with -
Never mind, Seth.
Point is, the Black communit
is owed an apology.
-But what did you think
about the debate itself?
-I thought it was familiar
Like, in a scary way.
Because it reminded me
of my brothers arguing
in front of my mom.
I was just waiting for a sanda
to come flying out of nowhere.
Especially when Biden told Trump
to shut up,
even my dog's ears perked up
He was like,
"Who you talking to, Jeff?
And I was like,
"Not you, Clifford.
It's okay. Good boy."
-Oh, your dog can talk?
-All dogs can, Seth.
If they like you enough.
Now, many Americans may have
been taken aback by the debate
but not the Black ones.
-No, no?
-Not at all.
That debate looked like
a regular Wednesday
at a barbershop.
It had everything you could find
at your local barbershop.
Two men
in desperate need of a haircut
and another sitting in the chair
telling everyone
it's the other guy's turn.
-Oh, so that's what goes o
at a barbershop?
-Yeah.
They don't do that at Supercuts?
-I don't go to Supercuts.
Plus you said that you would
take me to a barbershop
with you.
-I said that? I did say that
You know what?
But you have a show to do.
We can go after your show.
-Yeah, you said that
the last time, Jeff.
-I said that? I did say that
You know what?
I mean it this time, Seth.
-You said that
the last time, too.
-I said that?
♪♪♪♪
-"The Wright Thing"
with Jeff Wright, everybody.